The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Start
by reminding you
of what we did in last lecture.
And, in particular, there was
a little bit of confusion.
It seems like, maybe some
part, I went too fast.
So we'll try to-- yeah.
[AUDIO OUT]
So again, we start, say, by
choosing the worldsheet metric
to be the Minkowski.
Then the worldsheet
action just reduce
to that of a bunch of
free scalar fields.
Just reduced to a bunch
of free scalar fields.
And those free scalar
field is a bit unusual,
because, in particular, there's
a 0 component, which we have
a long sine kinetic term, OK?
But, of course, this
is not our full story.
You still have to impose the
so-called Virosoro constraint,
because [INAUDIBLE], the
stress tensor of this series
should be 0, which is the
consequence of the equation
of motion for gamma.
But nevertheless, you can write
down the most general solution
to this problem, so
let me write it here.
So the most general
of a closed string,
or the most general
conclusion can be
written as x mu plus p mu tau.
So I've now written,
what I called previous
by Xl and the Xr, I have
written them explicitly
in terms of the
Fourier modes, OK?
And I have written
them, explicitly,
in terms of Fourier modes.
And in this form, so you can
compare with what we discovered
before, previous,
here, because v mu,
then we discussed last
time, that this v mu
should be considered as
related to the center of mass,
momentum, over the whole string.
And, for example, for the closed
string, that's the relation.
OK, so similarly,
for the open string,
if you use the Neumann
boundary condition, here,
use the Neumann
boundary condition,
then you find, OK,
now we'll substitute
the explicit expression
for the Xl and the Xr.
So now, it become 2
alpha prime p mu tau.
So, again, this is
our previous v mu.
So this 2 is related
to the open string.
Sigma only go from 0 to
pi, rather than 2 pi.
And then, you can
write the oscillator,
this Xl Xr in terms of the
explicit Fourier transform.
So here, you only
have one set of modes.
And of course, n sigma
just come from you
have Xl plus Xr, and Xl,
which is equal to Xr.
And yeah, when these
two become the same,
when these two become the
same, then these two combine.
Because the sigma
have opposite sign
that combine to cause n sigma.
OK?
Yeah, it cause a m sigma.
So this is the most
general classical solution,
and in the light-cone gauge, we
say x plus can be setting to 0.
And also everything related to
alpha plus, and for tilde plus,
all the oscillation
modes also said to be 0.
We raise it to the
plus, set it to 0,
so there's only
[? tau ?] [INAUDIBLE]
left in the light-cone gauge.
And Virasoro constraint, they
become-- I have tau x minus.
So this v plus is
the same as that,
related to the p plus that way.
only single v plus.
OK, so you know the
equation, so the i
should be considered
as a sum, OK?
A sum of all directions,
or transpose directions.
So, from the
Virasoro constraint,
you can deduce X minus.
You can deduce X minus.
Yeah, again, let me just
write here, our convention's
always X mu is equal to
X plus, X minus, then Xi.
And i goes from 2 to D
minus 1, and X plus minus
is, say, 1 over square root
2, X0 plus minus X1, OK?
So, from here, you can
deduce the X minus.
And also, it means that
independent variables--
so this, we have determined
the X minus up to a constant,
because this determines the
tau and the sigma derivative
up to a constant.
So, the independent variables.
Xi, and then, also,
this p plus, or v
plus which appears in the
plus, and then the X minus.
The 0 modes for the
X minus, which is not
determined by those things.
And these two, this
is just a constant.
And, again, these
two are constant.
These are two-dimensional
fields, OK?
Any questions so far?
Good.
So actually, [INAUDIBLE] that
the zero mode part of this
equation particularly important.
Yeah, let me call this
equation 1, this equation 2.
So the 0 part of those equations
are particularly important.
And, for example,
say, from equation 1,
so the zero modes part,
for the first equation--
so let's do it for closed
string-- then zero mode part,
you just-- alpha
prime p minus, OK,
you should take the
root of alpha tau.
So you just get the
alpha prime p minus,
and the right-hand side.
So, right-hand side, let
me also rewrite the v
plus in terms of a prime, so
this is 2 alpha prime p plus.
And then, the zero mode means
that you integrate over,
you integrate over the string.
OK.
So this is the first equation.
So the zero mode equation
become like that.
So, now, let me just make
a brief comment, which
I, at the beginning,
I forgot to mention,
last time, which apparently
causes some confusion later.
It's that, if you look
at this expression,
this is actually
precisely-- so if you
look at that two-dimensional
field theory,
this is actually
precisely the Hamiltonian,
the classical Hamiltonian
for that field theory, OK?
For the Xi part.
This is just a free
scalar field theory.
Yeah, so, in particular-- so
let me write that more precise.
Let's take out this
p plus, and then this
become 4 pi alpha
prime, and then
this just become exactly the
Hamiltonian of that theory,
because 1 and 2 for the Xi, OK?
So H Xi is the Hamiltonian for
two-dimensional quantum fields.
Quantum field theory of Xi, for
the transverse directions, OK?
So you can also write
these explicitly
in terms of those modes.
In terms of those modes, then,
for example, you write p minus.
Yeah, if you can also write
modes, then become p minus.
You could, too, 2p
plus, pi square,
plus 1 over alpha prime.
So if you just substitute
those expansion into here,
then you can also write it
explicitly in terms of modes.
OK.
And then you can combine--
so this is p minus,
then you can multiply
this to the other side,
combine all the p together.
You can write it as M squared,
which is defined to be p mu.
P mu minus P mu P
mu, which is then 2P
plus P minus minus Pi squared.
And then, this then become equal
to 1 over alpha prime sum m
mu equal to 0 alpha minus
m i alpha m i plus alpha
tilde minus m i
alpha tilde m i, OK?
Then, you see that
this constraint
for p prime, for p minus,
now can be written,
can be rewritten in
terms of the relation
of the mass of the whole string
in terms of its oscillation
modes, OK?
In terms of its
oscillation modes.
And, similarity, for
the open string-- so,
this is for the closed
string-- for the open,
you could act the same thing
applies, just you only have,
now, one side of modes.
So remember, in those
expressions, sum over i
is always assumed.
And whenever I wrote
m not equal to 0,
it means you always sum for
minus infinity plus infinity,
and except where
m equal to 0, OK?
Yes?
Any questions?
So these are the consequence
of the zero modes for 1.
And the consequence for
the zero modes for 2,
again, you can
just integrate over
all direction of the string.
Then the left-hand
side just get 0,
because the x minus is
a periodic function,
so this is a total
derivative, and so
this is give you exactly 0.
And then, for the constraint,
on the right-hand side,
on this expression, which
can be written explicitly.
So you can also, then, plus
into the explicit mode,
and then they become sum m
not equal to 0, alpha minus mi
alpha mi equal to [INAUDIBLE].
OK, so this is sometimes called
a level matching condition.
So this tells you
that the oscillation
from the left-moving part--
this is for the closed string.
For the open string,
this equation just
does not give you anything.
For the closed
string, this gives you
a non-trivial constraint.
Oh, I got a ring.
So, for a closed
string, this just
tells you that the left-moving
part and right-moving part
have to be balanced.
And this is related
to that string.
It's periodic.
Along the string, it's
periodic, so there's
no special point on the string.
And then, there's no special,
and then you can actually not
distinguish between
the left-moving
and the right-moving part, OK?
Good.
So this is a the
whole classical story.
This is, in some sense, the
complete classical story, OK?
And then, quantum
mechanically, we just
need to quantize those guys.
Quantize those guys.
And those are just ordinary
quantum mechanic degrees
of freedom we don't
need to worry about.
And this just become
a quantization
of a free scalar field theory.
OK.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] all
these modes are massive?
Or is there any conditions
it can be massless?
PROFESSOR: No, this is
a massless field theory.
We are quantizing
this theory, right?
Yeah, so this is massless scalar
field theory in two-dimension.
STUDENT: But so that mass is--
PROFESSOR: No, this mass
is the mass of the string.
No, this is the
mass of the center
of-- this is the total
mass of the string.
When I say the massless, this is
a massless scalar field theory
in the worldsheet.
This is a spacetime description.
So it's important to
separate two things.
Things happening on the
worldsheet and things
happening in spacetime.
So this is the mass of the
string viewed as object
moving in the spacetime.
And when I say quantizing a
massless scalar field theory,
it's to think of
those, the mode.
So Xi is saying here, describe
the motion of the string.
Think of them as a field
theory on the worldsheet.
And that's a massless
field theory.
STUDENT: OK.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
definition of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It's the conserve the
loss of charge for the string.
Cause 1 into the translation.
It's to conserve
the loss of charge,
cause 1 into the translation.
Yeah, so that's what
we derived last time.
So be sure that this v--
but to be original, write v,
here-- are related to the
center of mass momentum
in this particular way.
Yes.
STUDENT: Could you use the
fact that the right [INAUDIBLE]
looks like [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry, which one?
STUDENT: The fact that
this alpha [INAUDIBLE]
P minus is actually
the Hamiltonian.
Can you use it anyway?
Or it's just the--
PROFESSOR: No, this is a remark.
And this will make
them more lateral.
For us, this is not
the essential remark,
but it will be more
lateral, when we work out
the zero-point energy.
And when we work out
zero-point energy,
then that's a more
lateral thing to consider,
because that will actually
give you a way of the computing
zero-point energy.
Yeah.
Yes.
STUDENT: So how do
you-- [INAUDIBLE].
If you plug in this
extension, does it really
direct me [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] n times--
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
STUDENT: Are you supposed
to have n time [INAUDIBLE]
times the other number of alpha?
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
what are you saying?
STUDENT: Here, if you
plug in this [INAUDIBLE].
And in the end, you've
got m times alpha m
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: But you directly
use this equation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: And you--
well, [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Oh.
This is trivial to see.
We can see it immediately here.
First, if you take the
derivative, we just get Pi,
and then you just get that term.
And when you take derivative
here, then you cancel the m.
And then, in order to
get the zero modes,
then the m and the
minus m have to cancel.
So the only structure that
can happen is this one.
Then, the only
thing left remaining
is to check the
quotient, here, is 1.
And that, we have to
do the calculation.
And the rest, you don't
need to do the calculation.
Yeah, the only thing to do the
calculation is for this one.
Yeah.
STUDENT: So just
kind of to bore you,
so all we're doing
is free fields
in a two-dimensional worldsheet
with the diffeomorphism
and variance as
a gauge symmetry,
and that gauge symmetry gives
us some complicated constraints,
which we then get rid of.
PROFESSOR: Solve the
constraints, yeah.
STUDENT: That's
all there is to it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
So, as I said before,
solving the constraint
help you two things.
First, you solve
this constraint.
And second, you get rid of
this X plus and X minus.
Because those are the
dangerous field theory, and now
we get rid of.
And what's remaining,
Xi, are good.
Will be, hey, they're good boys.
They're good, well-behaved
field theories.
Any other questions?
STUDENT: Yeah, one question.
So isn't knowing how to do,
basically, string theory--
well, is it knowing how to
deal with the Polyakov action,
and not in the light-cone gauge?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
But that take much longer time.
Even in the
light-cone gauge, I'm
still trying to telling
a long story short.
STUDENT: OK.
And so I'm trying to
give you the essence.
But make sure-- I'm trying
to tell you the essence,
but at the same time, I
want you to understand.
So make sure you ask,
whatever, it's not clear.
But, for example, in the next
semesters of undergraduate,
of string theory
for undergraduate,
you will reach this
point, essentially,
after maybe 15 lectures.
And we've reached here maybe
only two or three lectures.
And so, I'm trying to
just give you the essence,
and to try not to give you
too many technical details.
Say, cross checks, et cetera.
There are many cross checks
you can do, et cetera.
I'm not going those things.
Just give you the essence.
Any other questions?
Good.
OK.
So this is the review
of the classical story.
So now, let's do
the quantum story.
Again, this is a quick review
of what we did last time.
So, quantum mechanically,
all those become operators.
All those become operators.
And the alpha also
become operators.
OK, so this commutator,
as we said last time,
implies that 1 over
square root of alpha m i
should be considered as
standard [INAUDIBLE] operators,
for m greater than zero.
And the mode will
be [INAUDIBLE],
should be considered as
the creation operators, OK?
Creation operators.
And then, this is the standard
of quantization, or field
theory.
You reduce to an infinite
number of harmonic oscillators.
And in particular,
this product just
reduced to m times this Ami
dagger, Ami just become m Nmi.
OK?
So Nmi is the oscillator
number, occupation number, say,
for each harmonic oscillator.
Then, the typical
state of the system
just obtained by acting
those things on the vacuum.
For example, for
the open string,
we only have one set of modes.
So then, we would
have this form.
m1 m1 alpha minus mq,
iq, mq on the vacuum.
And the vacuum also have
a quantum number, p mu,
because those p, those
p plus and the pi,
here, are quantum operators.
And so, we take the vacuum
to be eigenstate of them.
And they're independent
of those alphas.
So this vacuum is the only
vacuum for the oscillators,
but they are still labeled
by a spacetime moment, OK?
So labeled by the spacetime
momentum of the string.
So for the open string.
And for the closed string,
similarly, you just
have two sets of modes.
Minus i1 n2 alpha
minus m2 i2 and 2.
And then, also,
you have the other.
let me call it k1 j1 l1 alpha
minus k2 j2 l2, et cetera.
In the vacuum.
So this is a typical state,
for the closed string.
But the allowed state should
still satisfy this constraint.
OK, should still
satisfy this constraint.
So this constrain
can be written as,
reach the following constraint.
It said, the oscillator
number on the left-hand side,
for the left-moving
mode, or tilde.
And the oscillator number
for the right-moving mode,
they have to be the same.
So let me rewrite this equation,
in terms of oscillator numbers.
So this means i sum.
So let me, now, write
them from m to infinity.
So m Nm i.
OK, so this just form
that equation, OK?
Yeah, so this is called the
level matching condition.
So, for closed string, you
cannot just act arbitrarily
alpha and alpha tilde.
The number of modes,
the total thing
you act from the left-hand
side, from the alpha
and those from the
tilde, they have
to be balanced by
this equation, OK?
Which is a consequence
that there's
no spatial point on the string.
So now, we can also
rewrite those equations
at the quantum level.
OK, so those equations,
the quantum level,
those equation just tells
you that, for those states,
the P mu are not arbitrary.
P mu are not arbitrary.
P mu must satisfy this
kind of constraint.
And that's can, in
turn, be integrated
as the determine the
mass of the string, OK?
Determine the mass
of the string.
So the mass of the string,
so then for the open,
mass of string can be written
1 over alpha prime sum
over i sum over m
infinity m Nm i.
Then plus some
zero-point energy.
So this is just the
frequency of each mode.
frequency of each mode,
a frequency of each mode.
And then, this is the
occupation number.
So this is a standard
harmonic oscillator result.
And then, at the quantum
level, of course,
there's ordinary issue,
because the alpha m
and m don't commute.
Because [INAUDIBLE]
creation, [INAUDIBLE].
So the ordering here matters.
So, in principle, yeah.
It matters.
Immediately, you can write it.
So that will give rise to
this zero-point energy,
or ordering number.
So, similarity, for
the closed string,
then you just have
two sets of modes.
Similarly.
that's a0.
So a0 can be-- so this is the
place this remark is useful,
because this just come
from-- essentially,
this part, just come
from, essentially, it's
just the Hamiltonian of the Xi.
Just the Xi viewed as a field
theory on the worldsheet.
And the field theory
of Xi, essentially,
is a bunch of
harmonic oscillators.
And for each
harmonic oscillator,
we do know what is
the ordinary number.
It's just 1/2.
Zero-point energy, just 1/2.
And then you just add
all of them together, OK?
Just add all of them together.
So, for example,
for the open string,
this just become
alpha D minus 2.
D minus 2 because that D
minus 2 derive directions.
And then, your sum m equal
to infinity 1/2 omega.
OK, 1/2 omega, and omega is m.
Then, I told you this
beautiful trick last time,
that this should be equal
to D minus 2 divided by 24 1
over alpha prime,
because this guy,
the sum over m 1 to infinity
m, give you minus 1/12.
OK, so this is for the open.
So, similarly, for
the closed string,
you can do the similar thing.
Just differ by sum 2, et cetera.
So this give you D minus 2
24 4 divided by alpha prime.
Closed.
OK?
So this vacuum energy--
So this can also
be integrated as a vacuum
energy on the circle.
Vacuum energy of this quantum
field theory on the circle.
And, in quantum
field theory, this
is sometimes called
the Casmir energy.
And you can check yourself,
that those answers agree
with the standard expression
for the Casmir energy
on the circle.
Yeah, if you choose here,
[INAUDIBLE] property,
because we have chosen
the sides to be 2 pi.
Good.
So this summarized what we did,
summarized what we did so far.
Any questions on this?
Good, no more questions?
Everything is crystal clear?
I should immediately
have a quiz.
Yes?
STUDENT: So the 26 dimensions
comes from making this 0?
PROFESSOR: No.
No, if you put the 26
here, this is not 0.
STUDENT: I'm sorry.
I'm thinking 1
over-- I apologize.
Not 0.
So, you said, the 26
dimensions comes from the fact
that, somehow, 26
minus 2 over 24 is 1.
It's like it's numerology,
but it's like--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, that's a very
good observation.
That's exactly the reason
I write in this way.
Right.
So let me just make a comment.
Maybe I make a comment later.
Anyway, so from here,
from these two expression,
from this expression
and this expression,
you see this picture, which
I said at the beginning.
So each of these describe
a state of a string.
And the state of a string, the
state of such a string, they
oscillate in this
particular way.
Say they have those
oscillation modes,
and then it moves in
spacetime, besides your center
of mass momentum, besides
center of mass momentum.
So such object, you
look at it from afar,
it's just like a particle, OK?
It's just like a particle.
So we have established it.
So now, let's look
at the spectrum.
So each state of a string
can be considered a map
to a spacetime particle.
So let's now work out.
And the mass of the
particle can be worked out
by those formulas.
OK, so let's now
just work out what
are the mightiest
particles, because we
are interested in the mightiest
particles, typically, OK?
So now, let's start
from the beginning.
with open string.
So the lowest mode, of
course, is just the vacuum.
P mu.
OK, there's no oscillators.
So, for such a mode, Nm i just
equal to 0 for all m and i, OK?
So this should be just
a spacetime scalar.
So this should describe
a spacetime scalar,
because there's no other
quantum number, other
than the momentum.
So it should be a
spacetime scalar.
It should describe
a scalar particle.
And the mass of the particle,
we can just read from here.
So the M square equal to minus--
so this is for the open string,
so we use this formula.
That's the only thing.
Because this here is 0.
So the only thing
come from a 0 term.
So you're just given by
D minus 2 divided by 24 1
over alpha prime.
So why you need
anything in lower case
is that this guy is smaller
than 0 for D greater than 2.
Say, for any spacetime
dimension greater than 2,
you actually find
the mass square,
[INAUDIBLE] mass square.
So people actually gave a fancy
name for such kind of particle.
They call it tachyon.
And, in the '60s,
actually, people
designed an experiment to look
for such particles, particles
of negative mass,
negative mass square.
Anyway, we are
not going to here.
Let me just say,
for the following,
in the theory, if
you see excitations,
if it's a negative mass
square, typically, it
tells you that the system have
instability, that you're not
in the lowest energy state.
That you are not in
a low-energy state.
So what this tells you is that
this open string propagate
in the flat Minkowski
spacetime may not
be the lowest configuration of
the string, but that's is OK.
If you're not in the
lowest configuration,
it's not a big deal, and
it just means you have not
found the correct ground state.
It does not mean the
theory is inconsistent, OK?
And so, even though
this is unpleasant,
this thing is tolerable, OK?
This thing is tolerable.
Any problem with this?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
You already set
[INAUDIBLE] m equal to 0,
so that is the ground state.
PROFESSOR: No, this is a
ground state on the worldsheet.
But in the spacetime, this
goes one into a particle.
This goes one into
excitation in the spacetime.
And so this goes one into
excitation in the spacetime,
with an actual mass square.
And, typically, if you have
something with a actual mass
square-- let me just
say one more words,
here-- then that means you are
sitting on the top of a hill,
and that's where you have
a actual mass square.
And so, it means you are in
some kind of unstable state.
But, of course, you are allowed
to sit on the top of a hill.
It's not a big deal.
STUDENT: Why is this
unstable, like a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: On the top of
the hill, is it stable?
STUDENT: No, why [INAUDIBLE]
means [? uncomplicated. ?]
PROFESSOR: Oh, if you write
a scalar field theory.
Yeah, so this goes one into
a scalar field in spacetime,
now, OK?
So now, if I write a scalar
field theory in spacetime,
say, let me call phi, with
a actual mass squared.
So that means, the potential for
this mass square is like this.
Then, that means that the
phi wants to increase.
STUDENT: Is that the
same thing as example 4,
with spontaneous--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's right.
Similar to 4, [INAUDIBLE].
Except, here, we don't
know what is the bottom.
We are just sitting on the top.
Anyway, so later, we will
be able to find the way
to get rid of this.
So it's OK.
So you don't need to
worry about this, here.
So the second mode,
the second lowest mode,
you just add alpha minus 1 on
this worldsheet ground state,
OK?
So now, this thing
is interesting.
First, this index i, this
index i is a spacetime index.
It's a spacetime index.
And so, this actually
means, this transform
means this state
transform as a vector
under So D minus 2 the
rotation of the Xi directions.
And, remember, in
the light-cone gauge,
the [INAUDIBLE]
symmetry's broken,
and this is the only
symmetry which is manifest.
And so, that suggests this state
should be a spacetime vector,
OK?
Should be a spacetime vector.
So now, let's work out its mass.
So now, m equal to 1.
So now, m equal to 1, and
so, you just have 1, here.
And so, then you
just put the 1 here.
So this is the alpha prime 1
minus D minus 2 divided by 24.
So this is 26 minus D
divided by alpha prime.
OK, so now you see the 26
divided by 24 alpha prime.
So now, you see this
magic number, 26.
So now, we emphasized before,
in the light-cone gauge,
even though only
this So D minus 2
is manifest, because you
break Lorentz symmetry.
The gauge break
Lorentz symmetry.
But your theory is still,
secretly, Lorentz symmetric.
It should still be
Lorentz [INAUDIBLE],
because the string is
propagate in the flat Minkowski
spacetime.
That means, all your
particle spectrum,
they must fall into
[? representations ?]
of the four Lorentz group, OK?
They must fall into the
[? representations ?]
of the four Lorentz group, even
though the Lorentz symmetry
is not manifest, here.
And now, let us recall
an important fact.
A Lorentz vector,
a vector field.
Yeah, just a vector particle.
In D Minkowski
spacetime, D dimension
of Minkowski spacetime, if
this particle is massive,
then have D minus 1
independent components,
so independent modes.
And if it's massless,
then I have D
minus 2 independent modes, OK?
So the situation we
have for many of these
is the D equal for four,
four-dimensional spacetime.
So in four-dimensional
spacetime,
a massless vector is a photon.
Photons have two polarizations,
have two independent modes.
But if you have
a massive vector,
then you actually have three
polarizations, rather than two,
OK?
But now, we see a problem.
Here, we see a vector,
but this factor only
have D minus 2 components.
Because i-- because these are
the only independent modes.
Here, we have a vector which
has only D minus 2 components.
Independent components.
OK, so if you compare
with this list--
because there's nothing else.
Because these are the only
independent modes, here.
In the last [INAUDIBLE],
there's nothing else.
So by compare with our knowledge
of the Lorentz symmetry,
we conclude the only way this
particle can be mathematically
consistent, we said, it has
to be a massless particle.
So that means M square
have to be 0, OK?
So M square has to be 0, means
that D must be equal to 26.
And we actually find
massless particles.
We actually find the photon.
So we actually find the photon
in the string excitations.
Yeah, one second.
Let me just finish this.
For D not equal to 26,
Lorentz symmetry is lost.
It's because that
means this particle,
where M square is not
0, no matter what,
these states cannot fall
into a [? representation ?]
of a Lorentz group.
And so, being said,
Lorentz symmetry
is not maintained, even
the Lorentz symmetry is
a symmetry of the
classical action,
but it's not maintained
at quantum level.
Somehow, in the
quantization procedure,
a symmetry which is in
your classical theory,
it's lost, OK?
And this tells you that the
quantization is not consistent.
It's inconsistent.
Because it means,
whatever it is,
if you have something propagate
in Minkowski spacetime,
is has two [INAUDIBLE]
[? representations ?]
of the Lorentz group.
That means that, yeah, this
just cannot be the right--
you have to go back,
to redo your thing.
This is not propagating in
the Minkowski spacetime.
So, alternatively-- so
this is a conclusion
that the D must be
equal to 26, OK?
So you can reach the same
conclusion the following way.
So, right now, so the way we did
this, we said we fudge this 0.
Yeah, we did not
fudge it, but we
did something to an infinite
sum, and find a valid answer.
Yeah, we have to do an infinite
sum of positive numbers,
and then find the active number.
And then we find, somehow,
there's something.
D minus 2 and D minus
2 somehow missing 1.
Anyway.
Anyway, but this is
actually a deep story.
It's not, say, just missing
1, or something like that.
So you can reach
the same conclusion
by doing the following.
Say, you put here a 0 as
undetermined quotient.
And it turns out, the same
0-- yeah, so you can check.
So here, it tells you that
Lorentz symmetry is lost.
So you can double check
this conclusion as follows.
So, remember, I said that
that classical action
is [INAUDIBLE] on
the Lorentz symmetry,
and then this conserve
the loss of charge,
because one to the
Lorentz transformation.
And those charge,
they become generators
of Lorentz symmetry
at the quantum level,
just in quantum field theory.
And then, by consistency,
those Lorentz--
conserve the Lorentz charges,
as a quantum operator,
they must satisfy
Lorentz algebra, OK?
Then, you can check
with a general D,
and with a general a0.
And that Lorentz algebra
is only satisfied
in the D equal to 26
dimension, and this a0 given
by these formulas.
OK, so that will be a
rigorous way to derive it.
Rigorous way to derive it,
but we are not doing it here,
because that will take
a little bit of time.
STUDENT: Does that also involve
the [INAUDIBLE] of the small--
PROFESSOR: Hm?
STUDENT: That [INAUDIBLE] of
the [INAUDIBLE], alpha mode?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yes.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
You're just assuming
some general a0, here.
You determine this by
requiring that the Lorentz
algebra is satisfied.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE], in
terms of this [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
in terms of alpha.
That's right.
STUDENT: Then, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, those
commutators are fine.
Those commutators are just
from standard quantization.
STUDENT: Oh,
there's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
which one over 24?
No, forget about 1/24.
There's no 1/24.
You just write a 0, here.
It's undetermined constant.
And check it by consistency.
Determined by consistency.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no.
Yes?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] we'll have
to work [INAUDIBLE] anyway.
So why do we worry so
much about [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
STUDENT: I mean, we'll have
to work D minus 4 dimensions
anyway.
So then, should we
just begin with, like,
Minkowski space D
is just not correct?
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah.
So will find, actually,
this conclusion
does not depend on the details.
It does not depend on details.
Yeah, so you can generalize
this to more general case.
Say, curve spacetime, et cetera.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
spacetime [INAUDIBLE]-- then,
you'll find the same
conclusion will happen.
The same conclusion will happen.
And then, you reduce
to four dimensions,
then you will find
the fourth dimension
a massive vector which only
have two polarizations.
Yes?
STUDENT: Maybe related
to this question.
We have no evidence that
Lorentz symmetry holds
in the compactified dimensions.
So why do we want
to keep it there?
PROFESSOR: We just
say, doesn't matter.
It's only a question
as far as you
have some uncompact directions.
As far as you have some
Lorentz directions, then
this will apply.
Yes.
STUDENT: Kind of going back a
little bit to the [INAUDIBLE]
thing.
How do we know for a fact that
the string tension causes--
because, for example, I
think, in QCD strings,
isn't string tension negative?
PROFESSOR: Not really.
How do you define a
negative string tension?
STUDENT: A negative tension?
I don't know.
I just read that,
the QCD string,
they have negative
string tension.
PROFESSOR: No, I think, here--
so alpha prime is a scale.
It's a physical scale.
Tension is-- it's
defined to be positive.
Just by definition,
it's positive.
Yeah.
Other questions?
OK, so let me just
say a little bit more
regarding-- so now we
have found a tachyon
and a massless
vector, and, also, we
have fixed the spacetime
dimension to be 26.
We have fixed spacetime
dimension to 26.
So now, if you now
fix 0 equal to 26,
then the higher excitations
are all massive.
OK, so for the photon,
essentially, it's this guy.
So this guy's inactive.
This guy cancel this guy.
So, when you go to
higher excitation,
then this guy will
dominate, and the m square
will be all positive.
And the scale is controlled by
this 1 over alpha prime, OK?
So will be all massive with
spacing, given by, say, 1 over
alpha prime.
So, we said, spacing m squared
given by 1 over alpha prime.
For example, the next
level would be-- so alpha
minus 1 alpha minus 1 some
i some j, or alpha minus 2 i
acting on 0, P, OK?
So those things acting
on-- to avoid confusion,
let me write it more clearly.
So this acting on 0, P, and
alpha minus 2 [INAUDIBLE]
on 0, P. OK?
So this would be like a tensor,
because these have two index.
And this, again, like a vector.
Again, like a vector.
So those would be, obviously,
the mass square of 1 over
alpha prime.
And you can check that,
actually, they actually fall
into the four [INAUDIBLE]
[? representations ?]
of the Lorentz group, OK?
For [INAUDIBLE]
[? representation ?]
of the Lorentz group.
Yes?
STUDENT: Where is the one with
only one index [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Sorry. say it again?
STUDENT: So the one with one
index, since it's massive,
it's supposed to have P minus
1 degrees of freedom, right?
PROFESSOR: They have-- oh.
What's happening-- that's a
very good question-- so, what's
happening is that
this should give
a tensor [? representation, ?]
but this not enough.
And this acts together to form
a tensor [? representation. ?]
Yeah, because i only going
from to 2 to D minus 1,
so you need to
add them together.
Good.
So just to summarize
story for the open string,
we find the tachyon.
We find the massless vector,
which can be integrated, maybe,
as a photon.
And then, you find lots
of massive particles,
infinite number of
massive particles, OK?
So any other questions, or
do you want to have a break?
We are a little bit out of time.
Yeah, maybe let me give
you three minutes break.
Yeah, let's have a break, now.
So, again, the lowest
state is just the 0, P.
And then, again, all the N is 0.
All the N are 0.
So we just read the
answer from here.
Then M square, for
the closed string,
you just equal to a0
for the closed string.
So, here, is now m squared
minus 4 divided by alpha prime.
D minus 2 divide 24.
So, again, this is tachyonic
for D greater than 2, OK?
Tachyonic for D greater than
2, and this is a scalar.
And this is a scalar, because
there's no other quantum
number.
Yeah, so now we are familiar
with these tachyons,
so we don't need
to worry about it.
So let's look at the next.
So, next, naively,
you may say, let's do
this one as open string case,
but this is not allowed.
This is not allowed.
Why?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's right.
It does not satisfy
this condition.
Because, this one, you only have
the left-moving excitations,
but does not have the
right-moving excitations.
You are not balanced.
So you also need to add-- so the
next one will be this guy, OK?
So, now-- oh, here, have a j.
Now have a j.
So this, we'll have m
squared 26 minus D divided
by 20 alpha 4 alpha prime.
6 alpha prime.
Again, now, look for what
representations of the Lorentz
group will give you this.
OK, you'll find none, unless
you're in the D equal to 26,
OK?
The same story happens,
again, only for D equal to 26,
fall into the representations
of Lorentz group.
And reach the m squared,
again, it's massless.
m square is massless.
So, it turns out,
actually, this does not
transform under any reducible
[? representation ?]
of a Lorentz group.
It's actually a
reducible, so it can be
separated into several subsets.
So this can be further
decomposed to--
So you can take all
the i and j together,
take the same i, some i.
So take this guy,
take these two index
to be the same, and the
sum of all the directions.
So this does not transform
under the rotation
of i's, so this is a scalar.
But it's a massless scalar.
And you can also
have the situation--
so all the state are in
this [? representation ?]
of both states, so
they are D minus 2.
So there are D minus 2
times D minus 2 of them.
D minus 2 times D
minus 2 of them.
So this, D minus
2, say, one of them
can be decomposing to a scalar.
And I can also take the linear
slope [INAUDIBLE] of them
with a symmetric traceless.
So the trace part is,
essentially, this scalar.
And I can also take
a traceless part.
Traceless e i j, OK,
because the trace part
is already covered by this one.
I don't want to repeat.
And this is precisely
the generalization,
what we normally call the
spin-2 representation,
to general dimension.
OK, so we have found a
massless spin-2 particle.
So this is a massless
spin-2 particle.
And then, you can
also, of course,
take it to be antisymmetric.
So that's the only
possibility, now.
bij, antisymmetric bij.
So these are called
antisymmetric.
So these will give rise
to an antisymmetric tensor
in spacetime.
So this is an object
with a 2 index,
and the 2 index are
antisymmetric, OK?
So, similarly, the higher
modes are all massive.
For example, at the next
level, next mass level,
m square is equal to 4
divided by alpha prime.
Any questions on this?
STUDENT: This antisymmetric
tensor, what is that?
STUDENT: It's like
a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's a
antisymmetric tensor.
STUDENT: But what's the spin?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, normally,
in the fourth dimension
will be something what
we normally call 1 comma
1, a representation
of the Lorentz group.
Yeah, it's not 0, 2.
It's what we normally
call 1 comma 1, yeah.
Yes.
STUDENT: It's a form
of bij [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, this
is just arbitrary.
Yeah, so this is your state
space, at this level, right?
And so, the general state
would be [INAUDIBLE] of them.
And those states, they
transform separately,
on the Lorentz symmetry.
So we separate them.
And so, for example,
symmetric strings,
they transform separately on
the Lorentz transformation
under these guys.
So this should cause 1 into
different spacetime fields.
So each of those things
should correspond
to a spacetime field, OK?
So, now, let me just
summarize what we have found.
So we have found--
so let's collect
the massless
excitations we've found.
Because, as we will see,
the massless excitations
are the most important one.
Let me also mention,
let me just emphasize.
In physics, it's always
massless particle give you
something interesting, OK?
For example, here,
even for D not
equal to 26, those massive
particles-- as I said,
maybe I did not emphasize--
even for D not equal to 26,
these massive particles that
do form into representations
or Lorentz symmetry,
for any dimension,
only for those
massless particles, OK?
It almost seems funny.
And so, of course, we also
know the massless [INAUDIBLE]
that give rise to long-range
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera.
So now, let's say, let's
collect the massless particles.
Massless excitations.
So we will write them in
terms of the spacetime fields.
So, for the open
string, essentially, we
find the massless vector field.
So this is our photon.
So, at the moment,
I put it as a,
quote, photon, because we only
find the massless particle.
We don't know whether this is
our own beloved photon, yet.
And, for the closed string,
then we find a symmetric tensor.
So this is what we
normally call the graviton.
So again, quoted.
We find the massless
spin-2 particle,
which, if you write
in terms of field,
would be like a
symmetric tensor,
Or B mu mu, which is
antisymmetric tensor.
And now, this mu mu, this
all wrong in all spacetime
dimensions, OK?
And then we have a phi.
Then you have a scalar field.
So this is just called
antisymmetric tensor,
and this phi is
called a [INAUDIBLE].
Phi, which is that scalar field,
is often called a [INAUDIBLE].
So, so far, even we
call them photon, call
this one photon,
and the h mu, they
are not-- to call them photon
and the graviton is, actually,
a little bit
cheating, because we
don't know whether they
really behave like a photon
or like a graviton, OK?
We just find a massless
spin-1 particle
and a massless spin-2 particle.
But, actually, there is
something very general
one can say, just from
general principle.
Just from general
principle, one can
show, based on
Lorentz covariance,
and, say, an absence of
[INAUDIBLE] physical states,
et cetera, say
[INAUDIBLE], et cetera,
just based on those
general principle,
one can argue that,
at the low energies,
that the dynamics of any
massless vector field
should be Maxwell.
And, for the massless
spin-2 particle,
must be Einstein gravity, OK?
So that's why, say,
tomorrow, supposing
if you mend this theory
yourself, and suppose
that's a quantum theory,
and that theory just
happens to have a
massive spin-2 particle,
then you don't have
to do calculations.
Then you say, if my
theory is consistent,
this spin-2 particle must
behave like a graviton, OK?
STUDENT: Are you saying that
there's no other Lorentz
invariant [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, essentially,
you can show, the low energies,
it's always just based on
gauge symmetry, et cetera.
The only thing you can
have is [INAUDIBLE],
yeah, is Einstein gravity.
Good.
And this can be, actually,
checked explicitly.
So now, let me erase
those things, now.
Don't need them.
So this can actually
be checked explicitly.
So, in string theory, not only
can you find the spectrum,
you can also compute
the scattering amplitude
among those particles.
OK, so I said [INAUDIBLE]
before, essentially, perform
path integrals with
some initial string
states going to some final
string states, et cetera, OK?
So, of course, this
will be too far for us,
so we will not go into that.
Let me just tell you the answer.
So you can confirm this.
So this expectation,
this confirmed.
This confirmed by explicit
string theory calculation
of scattering of
these particles, OK?
For example, let's
consider-- so we
have this massless spin-2
particle, which I called h.
So let's consider, you start
with initial state with two h,
then scatter to get its own two
final stage, which, again, h.
So this is, say, graviton
graviton scattering.
Start with two
graviton, scatter them.
So, as in string theory, we'll
be, say, at the lowest order,
we will have a
diagram like this.
So a nice [INAUDIBLE] order.
I'm not drawing very well.
Anyway, I hope this is clear.
So you start with two
initial string states.
You scatter into some
final states, OK?
So this is an obvious string
theory scattering diagram.
You can, in principle, compute
this using path integral, which
I outlined earlier.
Of course, we will not
compute this path integral.
And so, you see, there
are two vertex here.
One is proportionate to string.
You have two string
merging to one string,
and then you have a string
that's split into two.
So they're two.
Remember, each of
[INAUDIBLE] equals
1 and 2 [INAUDIBLE] string, OK?
So this will be the
process, in string theory.
process in string theory.
So now, If you go
to low energies,
low energies means
that, if you can
see that the energy of the
initial and the final particles
to be much, much smaller
than 1 over alpha prime.
So, remember, 1
over alpha prime,
it's the scale which go from
massless to massive particles.
So, if you can see the very
low-energy process, which
E is much, much smaller than
1 over alpha prime, then
the contribution of the
mass-- so, in some sense,
in the string, in this
intermediate channel, when you
go from 2 initial
state to 2 final state,
this intermediate channel,
the infinite number
of string states can participate
in this intermediate process.
But, in the process, if your
energy's sufficiently low,
then, from your common sense,
we can do a calculation.
And then, the contribution
of the massive state
becomes, actually,
not important.
So, essentially,
what is important is
those massless particles
propagating between them.
And then, you can show that it's
actually just precisely reduced
to the Einstein gravity.
Precisely reduced
to Einstein gravity.
So more explicitly-- so yeah,
so when you go to low energies,
then only massless modes
exchange, dominate.
Terminates.
And then, you find that the
answer is precisely agreed
in the [INAUDIBLE] limit.
Agree with that from
Einstein gravity.
Because you not
only have graviton,
you also have this B and phi,
they are also massless modes.
So this is a slight
generalization
of Einstein gravity.
It's Einstein gravity coupled
to such B and the phi, OK?
So, in fact, you can write
down the so-called low-energy
effective action.
So-called low-energy effective
action, and we call LEE, here.
let me see, like this.
So phi is this phi, here, and
R is the standard reach scalar
for the Einstein gravity.
H is this reindexed
tensor formed out of B.
So H square just a kinetic
term for B. So, more precisely,
you can show that the
scattering amplitude
you obtained from
string theory, then you
take a low-energy limit, that
answer precisely the same
as the scattering amplitude you
calculated from this theory,
say, expanded around
Minkowski spacetime, OK?
So this is Einstein
gravity coupled
to [? home ?] scalar field, OK?
Yes?
STUDENT: So what
about higher loops
or higher energies [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Of course, then,
it will not be the same.
This is low-energies, OK?
So let me make one more remark.
Make one more remark.
In Einstein gravity,
say, like this.
So Einstein gravity coupled
to the matter field.
So, when I say Einstein
gravity, I always
imply Einstein gravity
plus some other matter
field which you can add.
So, in Einstein gravity,
start your scattering process.
It's that lowest
order, we all know,
is proportional to G Newton .
OK, so this is the same G
Newton, the G newton observed.
Yeah, let me call this, say,
scattering for this is A4.
And then, the scattering
for the Einstein gravity
is proportionate to G Newton.
So one graviton is
changed, and it's
proportionate to
Newton constant.
This is an attractive
force between two objects.
And, if you look at
this string diagram,
then this string diagram is
proportional to gs square.
So we conclude that the relation
between the Newton constant
and the string coupling must
be G Newton proportional to gs
square, up to some,
say, dimensional numbers
or some numerical factors.
So this is very
important relation
you should always keep in mind.
So now, here's the
important point.
[INAUDIBLE] just asked, what
happens at the loop levels?
So you can compare the
three-level processes,
because, actually, find
they agree very well.
We say, what happens
at loop levels?
So now, let me call
this equation 1.
So, at loop level, this 1
is notoriously divergent.
So if you can calculate
some scattering amplitude
to the loop level, then find
the results are divergent.
In particular, more
and more divergent
when you go to more and
more higher loops, OK?
More divergent at higher orders
in [INAUDIBLE] series, say,
at the higher loops.
So that's what we normally mean,
say a theory is non-realizable.
So this tells you-- so, if
you take this gravity theory--
so this is just, essentially,
our Einstein gravity
coupled to some fields-- if
you take the Einstein gravity,
expand the long
flat space, quantize
that spin-2 excitations,
then that will fail.
Because, at certain point, you
don't know what you are doing,
because you get all divergences,
which you cannot renormalize.
OK, you can normalize.
So, of course,
what this tells you
is that this equation
itself likely
does not describe
the right UV physics.
So that's why you see
all these divergences,
because you maybe lost some
more important physics,
which you cannot renormalize.
But now, so this is supposed
to only agree with the string
theory at low energies, which
the maximum modes are not
important.
But, in string theory, there
are this infinite number
if massive modes, et cetera.
So you find, in string
theory, if you do similar loop
calculating string theory,
the string loop diagrams,
magically, are all UV finite.
Or UV finite, so there's
no such divergences.
There's no such divergences.
So this is the first hint.
So this was the first
hint of string theory
as a consistent
theory of gravity.
And because, at least,
at the pertubative level,
you can really quantize
massive spin-2 particles,
and to calculate their physics
in the self-consistant way, OK?
Any questions on this?
Yes.
STUDENT: In that
pertubation, you'd
have to use all those upper--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's crucial.
So that's why this kind of
thing is not good enough,
because that does not have
enough degrees freedom.
So, in string theory, you have
all these additional degrees
of freedom that make your
UV structure completely
difference.
Yes.
STUDENT: Then if you
take that [INAUDIBLE]
and you just [INAUDIBLE]
from above on [INAUDIBLE],
will it make [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so this will work,
as what normally works as a
low-energy effective theory.
A low-energy [INAUDIBLE].
When you consistently integrate
out the massive modes.
And yeah, so, even
at loop level,
this can capture, indeed, at
low energies, in my loop level,
this can capture some of
the string theory with that.
But you have to normalize
properly, et cetera, yeah.
Yes.
STUDENT: Does this imply
that, for large objects,
not things on these very
small scales, that we
should reproduce the
Einstein field questions?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: This is
sufficient to show that?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's
what it tells you.
Yeah, for example,
if you measure
the gravity between you and me,
you won't see the difference.
Yeah, actually, you
will see a difference.
So this theory is a
little bit different,
because of this
massive scalar field.
So, in ordinary gravity,
the attractive force
between you and me just
come from graviton.
But in this theory,
because this scalar is
massless and, actually, have
additional attractive force.
And so, this theory is,
actually, not the same.
So this theory, even though
it's very similar generalization
of Einstein gravity,
but actually
give you a different
gravity force.
So that's why, with
the string theory,
each going to describe the real
life, somehow the scalar field
has to become massive.
Some other mechanism has to
make the scalar field massive.
STUDENT: I see.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, of course,
we also don't observe B mu m
and this also, obviously,
become massive.
STUDENT: And will we find
out that's the mechanism
to make [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is one of the
very important questions,
since early days
of string theory.
People have been trying to look
for all kinds of mechanisms
to do it, et cetera, yeah.
STUDENT: So there is an
agreed-upon way of doing this?
Or is it still sort
of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: It depend, yeah.
This goes to a Lex point.
Yeah, wait for my Lex point.
Yes.
STUDENT: Can I ask, how do we
know that this effective theory
couples all the fields as
Einstein's theory does,
though quandrant derivative?
PROFESSOR: So what do you mean?
You can add-- the
coupling between them,
this and gravity is through
the-- Yeah, here, of course,
you should use
quadrant derivative.
Yeah.
Yeah, here, I did not-- I'm not
very careful in defining this,
but here, you use quadrant
derivative, et cetera.
STUDENT: What about coupling
to the open strings,
or to photons, or to matter?
PROFESSOR: Would
be the same thing.
STUDENT: As?
PROFESSOR: As what you would
expect, that [INAUDIBLE].
Just saying, it just governed
by general covariance.
General covariance have
to arise at low energies.
STUDENT: So that general
principle is effective
including matter, as well?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
then you can check.
They can check.
It it's a string theory,
anything you can check
is consistent with
that principle.
Good.
So now, it's another point.
So let me just
make a side remark
on the physical consequence
of this scales field.
So we see that this
scalar field is important,
because it, actually, can
mediate, say, attractive force.
But, actually, there's
another very important role
of this scalar field task.
It's that, if you look at this
low-energy effective action--
so let me now
write this G Newton
as 1 over g string square.
Then this have the
structure proportional to 1
over g string square times
exponential minus 2 phi, OK.
So now, there's a
very important thing.
So now you see, if phi
behave non-trivially--
this is, actually, modify this
guy-- it's actually factively--
yeah, because this is multiplied
by the Einstein scalar--
so this, effectively, modifies
your Newton constant, OK?
In fact, they modify
the Newton constant.
In fact, you can actually
integrate this gs
as the expectation
value of these phi, OK?
That's the expectation
value of this phi.
Yeah, because if you
can change your phi,
and then change
effective gs, then the gs
can reintegrate as
expectation value of phi.
So this is something very
important and very deep,
because, remember, gs is,
essentially, The only parameter
in string theory.
The only dimension is
parameter in string theory,
which characterize the
strings of the string.
And now, we see this
constant is not arbitrary.
It's actually determined
by some dynamic field, OK?
So that actually means
that, string theory,
there's no free parameter.
There's no free
dimensionless parameter.
Everything, in some sense,
determined by dynamics.
So this is a very
remarkable feature.
So this makes people think,
in the early days of string
theory, that you actually
may be able to derive
the mass of the electron.
Because there's no free
parameter in string theory,
so you should be able
to derive everything
from first principle.
Anyway, but this also create
a problem for the issue
I just mentioned.
Again, this is a side remark,
but it's a fun remark.
But string theory,
we mentioned before,
is a summation of a topology.
And the topology's
weighted by g string.
So, if g string
is small, they you
only need to look at
the lowest topology,
because the higher topology are
suppressed by higher power of g
string, OK?
And, particularly, if g
string become [INAUDIBLE] 1,
then, to calculate
such a scattering,
then you need to sum if all
plausible topologies, and then
that would be unmanageable
problem, which
we don't know how to do.
And so, want g string
to be very small,
so that, actually,
we can actually
control this theory, OK?
But now, we have a difficulty.
But we also said
we want the scalar
field to to develop a mass.
We want this scalar
field to develop a mass.
And, turns out, this
is actually not easy,
to arrange this scalar
field to develop a mass,
and, at the same time,
to make this expectation
to be very small.
K. And, actually, that turns
out to be a non-trivial problem.
Yeah, so it's actually
not that easy.
OK, so my last comment.
So, earlier, we
said, the tachyon.
So what we described
so far, these
are called the bosonic string,
because we only have bosons.
We only have bosons.
It's called the bosonic string.
So this bosonic string can
be generalized to what's
called a superstring theory.
Of course, superstring.
So what superstring
does is the following.
After you fix this gauge,
again, the superstring
can be written as some
covariant worldsheet theory
with some intrinsic metric.
And, in a superstring,
after you fix this gauge,
the worldsheet metric
to be Minkowski, then
the superstring action can
be written as the following.
You just, essentially, have the
previously free scalar action.
But then, you add some fermions.
You add some fermions.
So these are just some
two-dimensional fermions
living on the worldsheet.
Yeah, so these are
two-dimensional spinner fields
living on the worldsheet.
So the reason you
can add such a thing,
because those things don't
have obvious geometric
interpretation.
So you can consider them as
describe some internal degrees
of freedom of the string.
And so, these guys provide the
spacetime in the interpretation
of moving the spacetime.
And those are just some
additional internal degrees
of freedom on the worldsheet.
It turns out, by adding
these fermions, actually,
things change a lot.
Actually, they do
not change very much.
It turns out, things does
not change very much,
because this is a free
fermion series, also
very easy to quantize.
And everything we
did before just
carry over, except you
need to add those fermions
You need to also quantize
those free fermions.
Turns
Out, when you do that,
there are actually
two different
quantization scheme,
quantization procedure,
quantization process.
Two different
quantizations exist.
So, when you add these
fermions with no tachyon.
So, you actually can
get rid of tachyon
by including these fermions, OK?
So then, the lowest mode is
just your massless mode, OK?
And the reason that you can
have more than one quantization
is that, when you
have fermions--
and this is fermion
defined on the circle.
So fermion on the
circle, you can define
to be periodic or antiperiodic.
So now, you have some choices.
And, depending on
whether you chose fermion
to be periodic,
antiperiodic, et cetera,
and then the story
become different, OK?
And, sorry, we're
not going into there.
But, in principle, just waste
enough time, in principle,
now, you can do it yourself.
Because, just quantize
free field theory.
Actually, you still
cannot do it yourself.
Yeah, this there's still
a little bit more subtlety
than that, but the
principle is very similar.
So, in this case, you
get rid of tachyon.
So these two procedures cause
type IIA and type IIB string.
So they give you two
type of string theory.
One is called type IIA,
and one is called type IIB.
So, also, a lot of the
important difference,
instead of D equal to 26, now
only requires D equal to 10,
OK?
So now, let me just write
down the massive spectrum.
So now, because
you have fermions,
now, actually, this
spacetime particle
can also have fermions.
Previously, it's all
bosonic particles.
Now, by adding these
worldsheet fermions,
it turns out that
these can also generate
the spacetime fermions.
It can generate
spacetime fermions.
So now, the massive spectrum.
So now, these are
the lowest particles.
There's no tachyon.
So these, now, become all
10 dimensional fields.
So for type IIA, again, you have
this graviton, this B mu mu,
then you have this
theta [INAUDIBLE].
And then you have a
lot of active fields
come from the closed string.
And so, this is for
the closed string.
Now, you actually
have a gauge field.
Also, in the closed string, you
want gauge field and the three
form tensor fields.
So you have three
indexes, 40 antisymmetric.
STUDENT: Is the gauge
field just coming
from the fermion bilinear?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
That's right.
They are related, actually,
to fermion bilinears, yeah.
So those things are
exactly the same as before,
and then you get some
additional fields.
So these are normally called
the Ramond-Ramond fields.
And then, plus fermions.
So let me write
down the fermions.
It turns out that, these
theories, actually was magic.
So, each of those fields, they
have some super fermionic part
So it's actually a
supersymmetric theory.
So then, you also have type IIB.
And, again, the bosonic string,
you have H mu mu, B mu mu, phi.
And then, you have the
larger scalar field, chi,
then the larger antisymmetric
tensor C mu mu 2,
and it's in the four form field.
OK, so this, again, is
so-called the Ramond-Ramond.
Then plus fermions.
And then, the [INAUDIBLE]
theory of them
becomes, so-called, type IIA
and type IIB supergravity.
So these are supersymmetric
theories, and then
the corresponding generation of
gravity for the supergravity.
So we do not need
to go in to there.
Yes.
STUDENT: So, if you
were going to do
string theory, for example,
for a the generalization
on membranes, as you
had mentioned before,
if you were doing
this on two manifolds,
would you also have to
include anion contributions?
PROFESSOR: You may.
I don't know.
Nobody have succeeded
in doing this.
Yeah, you may.
OK, actually, today I have
to be particularly slow,
because I have a much
more grand plan for today.
That also means that
there's definitely--
you can only do the first
two problems in your pset.
There's only four
problems in your pset,
but you can only
do the first two.
So you want to start,
either, the first two,
or you want to wait until next
week to do it all together.
STUDENT: If we do it
all together next week,
so how about the next homework?
[INAUDIBLE] one week later?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, yeah, then let's
just defer to one week.
Yeah, next Friday.
Yeah, then the next
time-- so these, in sum,
conclude our basic discussion
of the string theory.
You have seen most of the
magics of string theory,
even though it's very fast.
So, next time, we will
talk about D-branes,
which is another piece of
magic from string theory.
Yeah.